this trial was a culmination of decades
of accusations pointing to a predator
hiding in plain sight
evidence robert kelly bribed a state
official for fake id so he could marry
the singer aaliyah in 1994 when she was
15 years old which the music industry
brushed over for some 25 years you have
to really look at this through the lens
of this is criminal behavior this is
behavior if it was any other person they
would have been in jail years ago
instead robert kelly rose to become one
of the biggest r b stars of the 90s and
40s working with the biggest stars in
the world
back in 2002 he was charged with 21
counts of making child pornography
charges stemming from a videotape
showing kelly having sex with a minor
sent anonymously to this journalist at a
chicago newspaper there was a manila
envelope with a vhs cassette no markings
on either when my partner at the sun
times abden palace and i did the first
investigative report in december of 2000
it had been going on already for nine
years
um we never thought uh when that paper
came out on december 21 2000 that this
would still be ongoing in 2021. so why
did justice take so long in the wake of
me too the mutar kelly movement
campaigned for labels and streamers to
boycott his music the reason why it took
30 years is because these were
young black women from chicago
charging kelly with racketeering this
time around meant prosecutors set out to
show the singer as the leader of a
criminal enterprise where managers
bodyguards personal assistants and
runners were all complicit in recruiting
women and girls for sex with him the
court heard graphic testimony from men
and women who claimed they were
exploited
robert sylvester kelly of course is
complicit the individuals who worked
with him either
as part of his production crew attorneys
individuals record companies the ricoh
statute in america the racketeering
statute which is generally used against
mob bosses and drug kingpins
we only have one person indicted how are
you a criminal enterprise if no one else
in your alleged enterprise is being held
to account fame brought him power and
protection but now the man who believed
he could fly has had his wings clipped
the spotlight now on those who enabled
him
katie spencer sky news